Film Courage: Shannan, for anyone who
knows nothing about screenwriting,
how would you begin to teach them the craft?
Writer/Instructor and Script Consultant
Shannan E. Johnson (The Professional Pen): Yeah
that's a great question because we all kind
of start from this place of not knowing
screenwriting unless you decide to go to a film
program that's actually teaching screenwriting
it's one of those things that is not a part of our
education system or anything like that so a lot of
us are starting from scratch. The great thing
about it being 2021 is that there are resources
everywhere so I actually just got this question
via email the other day and my first response
was just start writing it's kind of like even
if you are doing creative writing if you have
short stories that you're interested in if you
want to be a journalist and you want to write
articles you just have to start practicing it so
that's the first thing that you can do is just
start writing down your ideas the other thing you
want to do is then figure out how to hone that
craft are there screenwriting classes anywhere
whether they're in your area or they are virtual
are there screenwriting groups that are in your
area or virtual or go to youtube university which
is what we were talking about earlier and so
there are a lot of different organizations that
have pages like film courage like my page that
are teaching the fundamentals of screenwriting
because the biggest thing is understanding
the format which always tricks people up a
lot trips people up a lot and understanding the
structure the third thing you can do which is
just an addition to honing your craft is read
screenplays but make sure that you are reading
actual screenplays and not transcripts so a lot
of the times when people will google and look for
a particular screenplay the transcript will come
up and just so the difference the transcript will
be only dialogue and it'll all be formatted left
and it'll just be the dialogue from the screenplay
because someone actually watched the film and just
wrote down what everyone was saying but if you're
going to be the screenwriter you need to learn how
they are formatting the scene headings what action
looks like where everything is placed so you want
to make sure that you're looking at the actual
screenplay and not the transcript when you're
looking at those screenplays ask yourself what
you like to write ask yourself what you like to
watch so that you can then read screenplays that
fill in that format and that genre because each
genre is going to have kind of their own rules
and so you want to make sure that you're learning
how to write the thing that you're interested in
so what if someone says okay I've already been
working at writing a screenplay I actually have
four or five at home but I live in a small
town I have a family I have a full-time job
I don't know what to do from here yeah so the
first thing you want to do is get some feedback
on your screenplay because this industry is one
where there are going to be gatekeepers that are
going to be in place before you can get to the big
studios or the networks or production companies so
in order for your screenplay to get made at all
someone is going to have to read it and so you
want to make sure that your screenplay is in a
great place and that it's going to make it past
the reader so a great way to do that is finding
people like myself as a script consultant or
finding script coverage companies so that you can
get another set of eyes on those screenplays so
it's great if you have three or four screenplays
if you only have one keep writing get to your
three or four and then send them out so that you
can get feedback on them to see if they are up
to industry standard to see if there is an actual
story there now from there that's when it becomes
tricky because this is a who kind of industry and
if you are in whatever city outside of los angeles
new york atlanta maybe then it may be a little
harder to figure out how you're going to get in
so some of the options that you have are
screenwriting competitions competitions don't mean
that you will automatically get your screenplay
made but it's about exposure and access so if you
pay attention to which screenwriting competitions
are going to have who on their jury reading those
screenplays then you want to try to get in front
of those people so that they can help you to get
into the door the same thing is true for any
film festivals you can attend film festivals
and maybe meet some of the producers who are there
managers and agents who are there to be able to
talk to them about your work don't have your
screenplay printed out and pass it to anyone don't
do it don't do it keep your printed screenplay
at home but while you're there you want to be
networking and meeting people because since this
is a who kind of industry then you need to get out
there and meet some folks there are also different
kind of pitch competitions that are out there
that will also give you an opportunity to pitch
to people who are in the industry who then may
help you to develop your work to take it to the
next place if you don't want to do Hollywood at
all and you don't want to deal with a big machine
then raise your own money hire your own people
and make your own content because there are many
ways for you to get your own content out there now
so you said keep writing if if I just have one
or two screenplays what if my life story is so
fascinating I just have to get this story
you don't understand Shannan yeah I have to
get this story out yeah it's once you hear my
life story you will want to make this movie too
and I'm not looking to do other other stories
yeah if you're not looking to do other stories
if you don't want to be a professional writer I'm
going to say kind of the same thing applies to you
because unless you're going to find the money to
make it yourself you still got to get in to know
somebody to get them to make it so you're still
going to have to deal with those gatekeepers
so if your life story is so fantastic and so many
of us think that it is if your life story is so
fantastic then you need to find a producer who you
can prove to that person that it's that fantastic
someone has to get interested enough in the story
so you want to be able to have your log line ready
have your pitch ready have your screenplay ready
whatever materials you're going to have to be able
to show them like this is something that you want
to tell and if they decide to buy it and develop
it etc then they will but if you don't want to
be a professional writer you may say to yourself
but I don't want to go through all those hoops I
don't want to deal with that I want it made now
raise some money hire your people and make it
yourself because if it's the kind of story that
you just it's your baby and you just want to make
it then make it and air it to your family air it
in your hometown air it in your city you can
rent out a theater within the amc or whatever
theater you have in your community you can
rent out one of the rooms and show it on the
big screen and still have that same experience if
you're not trying to become a professional writer
so you just have to ask yourself what do you
want of that project realize what the different
avenues are and then choose one and hopefully
we'll get to see your story on the screen okay
what if I've heard a lot of bad stuff about
Hollywood and and I don't trust those people so
I i need you to get it out there for me because I
i just I've been warned me as in me or is this a
general question it could be you it could be it
could be me going to something but but we could
I could roleplay and say to you like I could
and so I I've heard stories and I just don't
trust it and I know that you could navigate
on my behalf so what you're looking for
is someone to be your representative those people
are managers those people are agents those people
are entertainment lawyers I'm a script consultant
so that's not my part of the job my part is to get
people from idea to pitch your representatives
then get you into the room to be able to pitch
and then you're going to pitch to executives or
producers or even actors or directors whoever it
is you can get in the room with so that it can get
bought developed and then made into into your film
or your television show so you want to make sure
whoever it is you're approaching is the person so
that means you have to start with research because
the thing about this industry if you decide to go
the Hollywood route the thing about this industry
is people care about you doing your part and you
doing the work so if you were to approach someone
who doesn't do that thing but you're asking them
for that thing then they're going to consider that
this is not something that you're serious about
so for example not every production company or
every studio makes the same kind of films or
tv shows so if this is a faith based production
company but you want to make a a vampire comedy
and so now you're pitching your vampire comedy
to this christian-based production company then
they know that you have not done your research you
don't understand their brand and now that is going
to look bad on you professionally so if you don't
want to do that bidding yourself great so that
means you need to find someone else who does that
thing who is that go between who is that liaison
who can do it for you so do the research to figure
out where the places that would make my kind of
movie or my kind of tv show who are the people who
I need to contact who have made their stuff there
because a lot of those studios are working
with the same kind of production companies
over and over again so then you figure out well
who do I need to have a relationship with to go
there so there's still going to be some work
on your part because if you don't know anyone
then you still have to find the people in order
for them to do the rest of the work so it's a
tough part of the industry which is why it's not
favorable for everyone it does take a lot of work
on your end and a lot of grit on your end and even
if you do have a representative if you are trying
to be a professional writer even if you do have a
representative the work doesn't stop for you there
so they're out doing some bidding but you're still
going to get most of the gigs because of the work
that you're doing yourself so if you're in a
position of saying that's not what I want to do
then maybe reconsider this may not be the industry
for you because there's gonna have to be work done
on your end and you're gonna have to get out of
your comfort zone okay and then lastly and and
I love this advice I've given my work's letting
me take two weeks to come out to la and I'm armed
with like five scripts I've talked to a couple
people on social media who say they might want to
produce it for me executive produce it I haven't
found too much about them online one of them says
they have their own company and they have money
that they can put behind it and they want to
meet so we're going to meet at a restaurant and
we're going to talk about them helping me make
my project how do I know that I could trust
this person well if you've done your research
and you haven't found anything you now have to
go with your gut go to the meeting listen learn
don't over share don't sign anything consider
this a part of your research when you're there
do you want them to take care of your baby that's
what this conversation is about everyone starts
from somewhere so maybe they are new in the
producing field so there isn't much online
about them just like you're new in the writing
field so it's not to say that just because you
can't find anything about them online means you
shouldn't work with them maybe maybe not you may
say okay well we're both starting out so we could
be starting this relationship together as issa ray
said you want to network this way and not this way
so if both of you are starting in the same place
take the meeting see what happens but while
you're in that meeting listen to yourself
listen to them and then make decisions
from there it may work out it may not
but that's going to happen no matter who you
decide to work with now if you do see a lot
of negative stuff online then don't take the
meeting there's no reason to take the meeting
if you can't find anything then take the meeting
and just listen learn have your questions ready
ask yourself what do I need to know in order
for me to feel comfortable with doing this
and then when you're in that meeting ask those
questions a lot of the times what happens is the
writer always feels like the person on the lowest
end of the totem pole which may or may not be true
so when we get into meetings with
other people we automatically get into
our own shells and think that we don't have a
voice to be able to request what we need but
if this is your baby and these people say they're
interested then you're interviewing them as much
as they're interviewing you so when you're
there ask the questions and if you don't get
the information that you need that makes you
feel comfortable with having a relationship
with them then you have all the information you
need shake hands don't burn bridges shake hands
say thank you and then find someone who is the
best for your project and I like that so issa ray
said network like this yeah network horizontally
instead of vertically she may not have used those
words but that's what she meant I don't remember
the actual quote yeah okay and sorry and so that
means then don't try to like be like this social
climber like do it with people that are starting
out at your level as well yeah it basically
means the people who you're starting out with
are all moving at the same time so that means
one of those people is going to be in a position
that can help you at some point just like
you might be in a position that can help them
so make friends with these people if
we're all assistants at the same time
we're probably all going to be executives at the
same time or one of them will become an executive
and i'll become a writer or another person becomes
a director and now going back to that who thing
now I'm working with the people that
I know because we started off together
versus everyone wants to get into the room
and they want to talk to steven spielberg
talk to steven spielsberg's assistant first of
all that's the closest person to him but secondly
that person has aspirations too most assistants
there's nothing wrong with wanting to be a
lifelong assistant we need people who are very
organized and get things done but most assistants
are there because they're trying to get somewhere
else and that's just the path that they chose to
get experience so that person may want to become
an agent that person may want to be a manager
that person may want to be a director if you get
a relationship with them because both of you are
in a place where you can build a relationship in
the first place because you're not going to get
to steven spielberg and make a relationship just
because you're on set one day but if you're nice
to the assistant and you guys become cool then now
you start rising together and you have the people
that you need when it's time to take a meeting
you can call over to this place because the person
that's working there because you guys were both
pas on some random music video five years ago so
I think it's really important as she said to
make sure that you don't ignore these people
just because they haven't made it yet because
some of them will maybe you will maybe you won't
but instead of jumping over those people and going
to the people who are already in place who don't
have time for you let's just be honest they don't
have that kind of time so instead of trying to
jump to those people pay attention to the people
who are grinding at the same time that you are
so we touched on some excellent points the way
to start screenwriting let's talk about the wrong
way to start oh that's the question yeah that's
a question sorry I think this offshore no it's
okay okay I think the wrong way to start is
just assuming how this thing works assuming
that what screenwriting is and so you don't have
to do any research that you don't have to try to
hone your craft in any way that you don't have to
read any screenplays that you can just wake up and
write and even though I said earlier writing is
a part of it that's the first thing you want to
do you want to start getting your ideas out to see
what they are but then to assume that that's all
it takes is the wrong place to start it's also the
wrong place to start to assume that you don't have
to know anything about the business as writers
you're your own advocate you are your business
and you're walking into a business so as much as
it's creative there's also the business part of
it and so you can have the best screenplays out
there but if you don't know how to play this game
of getting into the business then you're not going
to be in the mindset of it and also assuming that
you're just gonna be able to jump in like there is
like there's no putting in the midnight oil what
I mean of realizing that this is a long game this
Hollywood thing is long game so going back to that
networking across thing five years from now 10
years from now all of those people are gonna be in
different places not two days from now so the same
thing is true with your writing it's a process so
going back to knowing the business realizing that
I can write a screenplay today and it might not
get made until seven years from now so realizing
that it's not a quick thing it's not an in and
out kind of machine which is why you have to ask
yourself what is it that I want from this what
is my end goal am I trying to be a professional
writer am I just trying to get this one thing done
and if it's only that one thing do I really want
to put the time and energy into doing it another
place that you shouldn't start from is thinking
that the writer has total creative control
this is a collaborative effort filmmaking is
so realizing that there will always be someone
critiquing your work always always always always
and then learning how to separate yourself from
that so you aren't taking taking it personally
a no to your work is not a no to you as a person
like take that in breathe it understand it that no
to your work may mean this is not the work for our
company it may mean this is not what we're looking
for now it may mean there's growth necessary on
your part that's good information to hear you want
to hear great I need to grow because now what to
what to work towards versus not hearing anything
at all because that happens in Hollywood too
where people just don't respond to you at all you
don't get anything but getting that no tells you
I now am open to try to sell this somewhere
else this wasn't the fit for it and getting that
information so I know a lot of people say you need
tough skin when you come into this this industry
and yes that may be true but if you can learn how
to disconnect from your work equaling your worth
then the tough skin is not necessary as much
because that they're not critiquing you they're
talking about what's on the page and when someone
else develops it or someone else purchases it
they're now trying to get it to fit the mold
of their brand which is why you have to do your
research at the first place to ask yourself
is this the best place for my baby is this
the best place for my story if you decide to pitch
something to nbc it's got to feel like nbc so that
means the executives are going to mold it into nbc
that means they might lose trim some of the stuff
that you think is very important it may mean
that they're going to add some stuff that you
never thought about that's going to make this the
best show to ever hit television so you have to
be open to that collaborative process so I think
those three or four things are really important
that if you're not understanding that
you're starting off in the wrong place
can you have thick skin tough skin
and not be callous yes I think so
I think that thick skin that people are talking
about is being able to receive feedback not take
it personally and then therefore not react from
an emotional place and start to burn bridges
with that being said there are plenty
of callous people in the industry
a lot of the people who tell people they need to
have tough skin don't have tough skin themselves
everyone is sensitive and in the world that
we live in now everyone is sensitive and then
you come into an industry where we are
creating things and like erica badu said
people are sensitive about their stuff so I think
that thick skin just really comes from a place of
understanding that this is not about you and it's
about the work and the stuff but you are going to
deal with all kinds of different personalities
just like you would in any kind of industry
there are people who are not so nice here there
are people who are rude here and then there are
people who aren't and there are people who want to
help you and there are people who want you to grow
but at the end of the day you're still going to
hear no more than more than you hear yes someone
does have to approve and accept and affirm the
thing that you're giving to them and oftentimes
you're not going to hear the thing you wanted
to hear and if you don't know how to disconnect
if you don't know how to grow that tough skin
that they say then it can start to chip away
at who you are and that should not be the
end goal so yeah I think you can definitely
have tough skin and not end up being a
callous person but it takes work it takes work
and then you also said not knowing the industry
so if I want to jump in one of the wrong ways is
to not do research on the industry and who I'm
pitching and different things like that what if
I say what I'm just really good at winging it I've
always been good at sports I can fit into any room
I'm a chameleon in some ways I don't really need I
can just just get me there and and i'll know who's
in charge yeah I have a radar for that do it try
it out because at the end of the day no one has
the same true Hollywood story everyone gets into
this industry in a different way so if that's your
strong suit getting into the room and selling
yourself the hard part is getting into the room
when you get in there let your personality shine
do the thing that works for you because nine times
out of ten if that works for you in other places
it'll work for you here as long as whatever it is
you're saying can actually be backed up by what's
on the page a lot of people think what's on the
page is fantastic and wonderful and it just isn't
so now you went into the room and you oversold
you went into the room and you said I have this
thing and then we read this thing and it's like
no you don't so making sure that you're not
going to oversell because now people are going to
remember that you may not be able to get into the
room the next time but other than that if you're a
winged kind of person wing it the question is how
do you get in the room in the first place in order
to wing it that's why you have to know about the
industry do you ever see that where someone who's
kind of under confident they actually have really
excellent work yeah and it's the ones that are
like beating the the chest and wait you just have
got to see and it's like might not be there yet
almost always it's almost always that and
I say almost because there are outliers but
it's almost always that usually the people the
more introverted more I'm not really sure what's
happening here you read their stuff and it's like
you got something here you can be confident about
that and then it's the people who say I know I
have this thing you read it and it's like you
don't know how to format a scene heading so no
you don't have this thing quite yet so yes it
happens all the time and this is not necessarily
an industry that expects people to be humble what
I mean so I don't I don't my I don't mock them for
being overconfident however that thing on the page
is what represents you period it doesn't matter
what's coming out of your mouth what I mean so you
have to be able to back it up which is why I said
earlier you need that other set of eyes you need
someone you can trust on your team as a script
consultant that's what I become I become a part
of your team everybody needs a script consultant
even if they don't know that we exist but once you
find someone you need someone who can objectively
look at your stuff and let if you're doing the
thing you intend to do good or bad and if we don't
have those checks and balances then all we have is
our own confidence all we have is our own ego and
you can sometimes oversell what you have going on
but I don't think your overconfidence is bad what
I mean I would rather that than you falling apart
because you get a no what I mean but really trying
to make sure that whatever it is you're selling
can be seen on the page is the most important
thing there are plenty of people walking around
Hollywood with egos we we have a lot of those
so I'm not going to say you can't have an ego
sure you can what I mean but you got to be
able to back it up well what if I said though
what I ran this by my brother-in-law and he owns
his own company and this guy he knows his stuff
so it's already good I already know that yeah
does he know screenwriting no but he's built a
business and he's very successful look at the end
of the day I'm always going to say try it try it
go with it send your screenplay to one of these
script coverage companies send your screenplay
to me send it to a competition send it to a film
festival and see what happens because maybe you're
I'm not going to say that you don't have natural
talent I have natural talent I've sent screenplays
out that haven't been looked at by other people
and they've done decently well so I can't say that
that won't happen for another person but at the
end of the day you want someone who understands
not only the industry but also understands writing
understands the medium of screenplays so that they
can give you actual criticism and critique if not
then it's just opinion like you can have your mom
or your dad or your brother read as much as you
want they'll like it or don't won't like it but
can they tell you why can they tell you how to
fix things or are they just giving more opinion
and everybody out there has got an opinion it
doesn't mean that it's going to make your story
better so if you feel that you don't need another
set of eyes totally fine put it out in the into
the universe and see if you get what you need in
return and if you don't then you'll have to change
your tactic just like your characters have to do
when they aren't getting the things that they need
are there any other best practices that'll help
someone get their start I think those first few of
knowing who you are as a writer what you like to
write what your end goal is and then honing in
on that to me and then obviously figuring out the
business figuring out the business is the hardest
part because just like there's no formal education
on screenwriting unless you're in film school
there's no formal education on the business
like you can even go to film school and not
learn the business that part's going to be more
trial and error but as far as those other things
those are kind of the best practices get out
there try and try again in the beginning stages
write all kinds of stuff and see what you enjoy
something that I ask my students is what do you
like to watch what do you like to write because
a lot of the times those two things don't add
up and so if that going forward I mean from from
the beginning then now you can make sure that your
your samples your materials actually add up to
what you want to do because if you're out in the
world saying oh yeah I love watching one-hour
dramas but you're writing half-hour comedies
then are you saying that you want to work in
dramas but for whatever reason you've been
writing comedies or do you actually want to write
in comedies and so now I should be reading those
comedy scripts instead of those one-hour drama
scripts even though I like watching those one-hour
drama scripts so really just trying to figure out
who you are as a writer what your end goal is so
that you can start working your way there and
then once you're in a little more you can start
concerning yourself with getting representatives
and getting all that other kind of stuff but it
really just starts with the craft and also
understanding that everybody out there is
just trying no one has the answer everybody's
journey into this Hollywood machine is different
if you decide to go independent it's going to
be different because you're doing it on your own
so just having the confidence to say if I've
decided that I'm going to sign up for this then
I'm just going to do it and I'm just going to roll
with the punches how they come are there any false
beliefs that new writers have that sometimes just
drive you crazy hmm false beliefs I think one of
the biggest ones is that they think it'll happen
overnight they think well I have this idea and it
really has to be on tv by next year because what's
happening now is is is so important that this
story has to be told and I can tell them I agree
with you the industry just doesn't work that way
all it just takes time so I think that's one of
the biggest ones is just not realizing how much
time it takes to do things I'm trying to think
are there any other false beliefs that people have
I think that's the biggest one yeah okay so I
mean let's suppose let's say I watched startup
or queen's gambit or one of these excellent series
and I want to do I have this great idea that it's
going to be very similar is that its own mistake
because it's already been done and it's already
been done so well why try to not necessarily not
necessarily in my opinion there are no new ideas
especially now Hollywood is big on reboots and
remakes so they're big on established ip period
so if it's already been done the question is
what are you going to do that makes it unique
what's going to make it different you make it
different first of all because your experience in
this world is different so if you decide to tell a
story about a kid who doesn't know who his parents
are and lives with his aunt and uncle who are
emotionally abusive it doesn't mean that it turns
into harry potter but it's still got the same
premise that this child is looking for identity
so it's okay if you've seen it you just have to
figure out what unique thing you're bringing to
the table the other thing is trying to follow the
trends of Hollywood some people are into trends
some people want to write what they are already
seeing on television because they think that's
what's being purchased I'm here to tell you
if you're watching it the trend has passed
in Hollywood the trends pass every few months so
whatever that production company studio network or
streamer was looking for in january they're not
looking for that same thing by june so if now
you're seeing vampires on every network and you're
working on a vampire pilot now in your house
doesn't mean don't write it but it does mean that
by the time you're able to pitch it to someone
we're not into vampires anymore we've moved
on so I tell people you have to decide if
you're going to follow the trends or not that
can be a good thing for you if you're already
a professional writer and you're already in
the game therefore you hear about the trend
before the trend starts so that yes you want to
be writing the thing that that they're looking for
because all of those studios etc have mandates
and so they can say at whatever part of the year
we're looking for vampire stories where you're
ahead of the game go write a vampire story but if
you are just starting out and you're seeing all
the vampire stories on tv or on the big screen
then that trend has already passed so then now
it comes to maybe I should just write what I'm
interested in period and when it becomes something
people want to read great or like I've said before
sometimes it's not about selling something and
it's about having it as a sample to show how
great of a writer you are because if you can write
vampires I'm going to assume you can write ghost
I'm going to assume you can write werewolves I'm
going to assume that you can write in this science
fiction fantasy world or maybe horror whatever
it is whatever kind of story it was so you can
still use that as a sample to get you into the
next thing it may not get purchased and if you
want to be a professional writer then I think it's
a great balance to look at anything you write as a
possible sample versus I have to sell it because
you don't have control over what happens on the
other side unless you're doing it independently so
if you write somethings I have to sell this then
now you're setting yourself up for disappointment
if you don't versus saying I'm writing a fantastic
sample and I'm going to show this to someone and
those people might like it and they might decide
they want to buy it now when now you have a win
but yeah I would say just focus on writing what
you like to write that's what makes it fun if
it's not going to be fun we could all be doing
something else we can all be we're we took on
this creative job because it's supposed to be fun
if it's not gonna be fun then we could be doing
whatever job someone else tried to push us into
what if I say well I'm gonna resurrect an old show
like the office but we're gonna all be on zoom or
or facebook live or google chat and we're gonna
just it's gonna be so cool and it'll be the same
office politics but now we're all virtual and
our bosses are spying on us at home yeah so
it'll be really cool and it's been a few years
since the show was on so I can resurrect it
maybe if someone out there is interested in it if
someone out there is looking for something like it
like I said before Hollywood is kind of interested
in established i.p at this point and not to say
that you would then have to get in touch with
the people who made the office and blah blah blah
have to be different enough because if it's the
same thing then now you're infringing on their
copyright so you're not necessarily making the
office unless you are there are a lot of reboots
that are being made now and they're making bel air
which is a reboot of the fresh prince of bel air
with the entirely different group of people but
that means that they went through the proper
channels to make sure that there's no infringement
etc etc so they can do that so instead of saying
you're making the office make something that is
new and original and say that it's like the office
unless of course you have the permission to be
making the office and doing it doing something
different with it but again like I said there
in my opinion there aren't any new ideas
I've had people pitch me the same idea in three
different states from three different people and
one of those pers people wasn't even a writer
and I was just like wow this is crazy how we're
all living in the same world now so we're
all getting the same information and that's
making a lot of us create the same ideas if
that makes sense so if there was something
about the office that you enjoyed ask yourself
what was it about the office that I enjoyed
maybe that's the thing that you take and turn
into your own thing because the office doesn't own
office politics if any of us have ever worked in
a corporate space then we know office politics so
the people who made the office don't own that
space what they did to make it different was
the way they filmed it the mockumentary style
et cetera et cetera but other than that it's all
the same stuff that we'd see in any other kind
of office so asking yourself what is it that I
liked from that and then how can I put that into
this idea that I have that's about zoom or about
whatever it is so that it I'm turning it on its
head so that there's something unique about it
and now I can utilize the office as proof that
this may work but I'm not necessarily selling you
the office so maybe like pam she was yeah okay
so let's say pam's character type let's see she
was the go-to gal and she knew where all the
staples were and and everybody kind of needed
her all at once so I'm going to make a series
sort of like based on her life but it's she's
going to be at home but it's not really taking
the office's ip it's just a kind of a caricature
exactly someone like pam if you decide
to make it pam then now you're infringing
but if you do something like pam because again pam
exists because that person exists in all offices
there's always somebody who knows where everything
is that maybe that's the coordinator maybe it's
the admin the the ceo's a administrative
assistant or whoever it is but somebody
in that office everybody knows I'm going to go ask
her she's going to be able to get it to me and ask
him he's going to be able to get it so that's not
a new idea so being able to say well that's what I
thought was interesting this particular character
knowing everything about the office so then
you have to then of course build your story from
there because that's a character that's not enough
to get you a story or a pilot or a series but
understanding that that's the thing that you're
pulling from then that can work for you so pam's a
remote worker but she has another job on the side
that her boss doesn't know about and she's doing
it on company time and it's a little bit more
nefarious and so she's have got to make sure that
she's on point for the office but then she's doing
I don't know she's taking adult surveys or she's
doing something that's like it's not horrible but
it's like whoa pam what are you doing right so
the balance of that will then be what the series
is about and then figuring out what the stakes
are that she is doing that like does she has
she signed some kind of clause in her everyday job
that says that she shouldn't be or can't be doing
this thing so that if they find out that she's
doing this thing then this thing is in jeopardy
so you have to ask yourself what is the story
someone doing those two things okay cool but
what do they have to do with each other how do
they crash into each other to cause a problem
like does she have a problem trying to balance the
two or what does it become so you still have to
then build out the entire story around pam or
the pam-like character to see what it's going
to become what is screenplay structure very big
question but I would look at screenplay structure
as how you tell a story and depending upon the
kind of screenplay you're writing the structure
is different in general we've all learned about
three-act structure in some way shape or form
that three-act structure can then be broken down
into just two acts if you're writing a half-hour
multi-camera comedy it can be spread out into
four or five or six acts if you're doing a one
hour drama but your half hour single camera and
your features are usually told in three acts
and if you want to break it down and make
it as simple as possible your first act is
your setup it's giving me all the information
I need to know of why I am here your second act
is the journey to reach the goal and then your
third act is what happened now that I reached
the goal so it's your resolution so you have your
setup your journey and your resolution and so if
you can understand that anytime we hear a story
bedtime story dr seuss what happened last weekend
we're all listening for the setup the journey to
success or failure and then what happened after
that so to me that's like the simplest way of
talking about what structure is for a screenplay
I like how you broke that down because when
we think about let's say a family friend or
a bunch of friends getting together telling a
story about what happened last weekend it makes
sense if they leave out the second act that's but
when we think about a story that we're writing
we could I could see where things would get
convoluted yeah because you also even if you
don't understand story structure you feel it so
you have a cousin or a friend who doesn't know
how to tell stories so they come in and they go
oh let me tell you what happened last weekend
and that this particular cousin or friend is
just going to talk on and on and on and on
and never get to the point of what happened but
amongst your friend friend group are amongst your
family they're like no no no let such and such
tell it because such and such is going to give
you the setup the journey and what happened the
resolution that you're going to get there that
they're going to give you the details that you
need nothing extraneous or they're going to say
quick sidebar and then they'll give you this
extraneous stuff and then they'll come back to
the story and keep you following the journey so
storytelling is storytelling and storytelling
no matter where you're telling it in a screenplay
it has to be more concise and it has to be visual
but even those people who don't specifically know
they can't give you the vocabulary they don't
have the words to explain how to tell a story
we're hearing people tell stories all the time
like going back to that office thing there's
somebody in your office who always stands around
the kitchen or whatever and they have a story blah
blah blah and you enjoy their stories and then
there's somebody else who always has a story and
you're trying to sneak away from the conversation
because you're going to be here for the next 15
minutes and have learned absolutely nothing and
so that's kind of how that your screenplay isn't
working because we're 30 pages in and I don't have
I don't have any information we're 30 pages in and
I don't know what this screenplay is about we're
30 pages in and I don't know why I've been dropped
into it I don't know what I'm here to witness
because there's a whole lot of talking and going
around the bend and over the river and through
the woods but I still having the slightest idea
what my protagonist is trying to do or possibly
who my protagonist is in the first place so
sometimes that happens but yeah storytelling
is storytelling so if we start to allow and it's
hard when you're the writer when it's on the page
because now there's all kind of pressure and
stress and stuff but if we allow ourselves to
step away from it and just look at it like any
kind of story we can ask ourselves like does it
feel like my story is moving forward or does it
feel like people are just kind of talking around
some things but that's why again people like me
exist because maybe you can't see that yourself
and I pride myself on being objective my students
tell me all the time your objective I even had
a student in one of my classes on the university
level said can you teach the rest of our teachers
how to be objective in this way because when
I read their stuff I don't make them become
a particular kind of writer I'm able to look
at them as individuals which means they write
the way that they write it's not my job to make
them fit into this box but a lot of the times
you may send your work out and what you receive
back is a whole lot of opinion about what your
writing should be and you should change this
and it should be this you should have that
blah blah blah and it's like well that's a great
story but that's not my story that's not the one
that I'm trying to tell so finding someone
else who can objectively look at your stuff
they can help to help you to understand that your
story is kind of going around in circles and not
pushing forward just like when uncle such and such
starts telling a story whether it's a drunken one
or not he's never going to get to the point guys
we can go continue playing our basketball game
so when you say that you like to to work with
people and and find out the way they tell a
story and who they are how like how is that
because because so somebody could say well
this is just who I am and I i don't really like to
formulate full sentences and I'm just this is just
my style yeah is that acceptable if it's working
okay that's why you have to be objective because
sure we can say I need full sentences but if it's
working if the fact that they're shortening their
sentences is helping me to feel the tone that
they're setting helping me to feel the urgency
of the story I read a screenplay the other day and
every single line of action was just one sentence
but it made the story simple because it was about
a simple guy doing a simple thing I didn't need
more but if this were a more convoluted premise
if it were a more dramatic story where I needed
to feel more things etc then now my note would
be I need more and here is why but I was able
to tell this particular writer usually I would
say I need x y and z but this is working for you
because I also want them to know the rule I also
want them to know someone else might read this and
say x y and z but it's working for you the same
thing is true with I sometimes have people who
instill their voice too much as a writer and so
it's jarring now I'm hearing you and it's pulling
me out of the story sometimes that works though
same thing with camera angles it's a no-no for
writers to infuse camera angles in their
screenplay because it's distracting to the reed
I'm into something emotional then here you come
with big capital letters close in I already know
that I'm close because I feel it because I'm
reading the story and now you just ruined it for
me by yelling close in as if the director won't
feel that from the context that you've set up but
then I read somebody else's screenplay and they
didn't use it a lot but the moments that they did
worked it felt it didn't pull me out so that's
what I mean by you have to be objective to the
story you have to understand what is this story
trying to do what does it feel like what's its
tone what's its writer's voice what is it
intending to do and are they doing that and
if they are then why would I tell them to take
away the things that are making that thing happen
so if we took let's say a young
charles bukowski in a writing program
and there's just one way to do this
and then he's presenting this work that
might be might raise some eyebrows
but that's who he was that's his style
and and maybe he just didn't find the teacher yeah
I mean and the thing is not everyone's a teacher
just because how to write doesn't mean how to
teach people how to write that's just the truth
of it and I think we take the whole we take
the education part of it not seriously enough
so maybe that is the case because also teachers
are only teaching what they've been taught
depending upon how much experience you've had in
the industry you may think it has to be this way
because I was taught it has to be this way
but if you're continuing to read screenplays
even as a professional writer you'll see that
people break rules all the time people are doing
stuff all the time people make terrible stuff
that makes it onto tv and onto the big screen
all the time so why would I tell my client that
wouldn't work you can't do that it's just not
true you can do anything you want now I'm going
to tell you what the industry standard looks like
I'm going to tell you what people expect but do
you because maybe it's going gonna work now there
are some things that you just can't do like if
it's if it's unreadable then it's not gonna work
what I mean if I can't follow the story because of
whatever risk you're taking or creative licenses
you're taking then it's just not going to work
but if I can follow the story and I understand
the story a lot of those rules really do fly
out of the window they really do I'm going to
teach you what those rules are but again if it's
working then I'm not going to stop you from doing
the thing that's working think about aaron sorkin
and how much dialogue are in his screenplays
we're told all the time you can't have that much
dialogue you can't have that much dialogue think
about shonda rhimes and how many monologues she
has in her screenplays and we're told all the time
can't have monologues can't have monologues where
here are two examples where it's working very well
for these two people so I just don't believe in
the extremes I don't believe in yes this is going
to work and no that's not going to work because
Hollywood lives like in that in-between space and
I think the reason I can give that information
is because I have the experience to know
and then also because I am a teacher so I am
trying to teach you to fish and not giving
you fish so I'm always going to give you the
why the how the possibilities the what-ifs
and sometimes that doesn't work for people
because they need to know exactly what it is
but I try to explain to them Hollywood is
not one of those places not black or white
it really isn't it's all that stuff in
between so you're trying to write a story
that is well executed that's that's doing what you
intended to do that you're gonna be proud of that
represents you as a writer because all of us are
gonna look back on something that we wrote and go
oh my god that's terrible oh I can't believe I
wrote that so you're gonna grow from it anyway
so you just have to get to a place where
you're happy with it and it represents you so
for someone like aaron sorkin or even tarantito
I'm sure there were people telling them this is
too much dialogue I'm sure of it but they were
able to get in with whichever way they got in
because I don't know their stories but however
it is they got in and it worked out for them
how is screenplay structure different from
outlining a screenplay oh I actually don't
think it's different at all your structure
should be there from the beginning and if
you're outlining from the beginning you should
be able to follow your structure there to me the
biggest difference is in my opinion I look at a
beat sheet like one-liners of your biggest moments
and then I look at an outline of fleshing that
out so that now exactly what's happening in every
single scene not necessarily just those big beats
even though for some people that's all they need
but now you start to see the connecting beats
that get you from the large beats to the next
large beats and then the screenplay is actually
the creative part of writing out the scene
so that's how I explain it to my students some
people don't make beat sheets some people just
make outlines some people don't make outlines and
they just make beat sheets and some people just
write the screenplay you have to figure out what's
best for your process in my opinion you want to do
some work before you get to that screenplay
because the white page is intimidating
and if you don't know where you're going it will
eat you alive so just like with your google maps
you got to put in the address and know what
you're following even if you decide okay I'm
going to shut it off now I kind of know where I'm
going I don't have to keep looking at my gps great
same thing for your beat sheet or your outline so
for me I usually use the pixar formula as my beat
sheet I love the pixar formula if you're looking
for one you can go google it now I've added some
things to my pixar formula for my students because
there's some more emotional work I want them to do
before they get past this point but basically
it asks you about the beat sheets not the beat
sheets the big beats starting at once upon
a time and now you have this layout of what
your story is that you can post next to your
computer or wherever it is you want to put it
so that you always know where you're going because
as creatives we will veer off the road and that's
how we end up with uncle such and such a story
that never makes it back to where it's supposed to
be so if you have your outline or your b sheet or
your pixar formula or whatever it is that you're
using you always have something to come back
to to go oh yeah because you also have another
uncle who's like where was I what part was I on
blah blah blah blah well now you don't have to
ask anyone it's here you've written it down where
you're going and because every scene is supposed
to be cause and effect what happens in this
scene is because of what happened in that scene
then looking at that beat sheet lets these are
the scenes that I need to get to the next beat
and these are the scenes that I need to get to
the next beat because that the point is I need
to get from a to b to c to d to e whatever for
some people they only need to know a g m and z
I need to know a through z so my outlines are
a long my outlines can be 60 pages long if I'm
writing a feature and if it's like I did one
and I want to say it was somewhere between 30
and 50 pages long because it was a feature and it
was science fiction so there was a lot of stuff
and rules that you have to figure out if you don't
know the answers to those questions you don't want
to get to the page because then you can kind of
get lost in the sauce but some people don't need
everything written out I like it all to be written
out because I also do my revising in the outline
so as I start writing the screenplay and new
things do come because the outline doesn't
have to make it's not in concrete so new
things do come oh that's great that's good
what you now have to realize though is that new
thing is going to affect the outline what's coming
next maybe what came before it so now you can
go back to the outline and go okay I got this
new thing so let me move this copy and paste move
that around blah blah blah and now you can see
what the new story looks like without having to
do it in the screenplay which takes a lot longer
believe me I've done it so I utilize my outline
throughout the entire process which is why it's
so much longer but back to your original question
the structure is there that's why you're outlining
structure needs to be there if you're outlining
and there is no structure your screenplay won't
have any structure so the outline tells you
what and what you don't know if you're outlining
correctly I'm actually in the middle of teaching
my outlining class now it's called idea to story
2.0 I have it online for people to purchase to do
it at their own pace but then I do it once a year
where you get me live and so we're now going
through all of those moments because I feel that
if you have a an effective outline then you will
write your screenplay far more efficiently and so
I give them workbooks and worksheets that they can
do throughout that they can do with any project
they're doing but mostly so they can eventually
figure out what their process is because they
all may decide I don't need this worksheet I don't
need that I don't need to do this outline but if I
do this thing this is the thing that I need that
helps everything to open up so I'm just trying to
help them to figure out what their process is
while teaching them structure and then hoping
that they decide to do outlines forever but they
may not so that's kind of a go go at your own
pace you said I have two two characters so the
first idea of the story is go at your own pace
you get all of the videos all the worksheets et
cetera and you can just watch them on your own and
figure it out as you go and if you have any
questions then you can sign up for kind of like
an office hour thing with me and then i'll kind of
talk you through your homework if you sign up for
the live version which I only do once a year then
we spend two or three hours of lecture every week
and then 45 minutes to an hour of just one-on-one
talking about your story because if you take a
screenwriting class a lot of the times you're
in taking the general information but you're
not translating it to your story so the only way
that I know that they actually learned what social
proof was is if I start talking to them about
their characters and social proof I only know
if they really understand an inciting incident if
I'm talking to them about their inciting incident
and what information we got in during the normal
before the inciting incident so on and so forth
and so I think people enjoy that part because then
they start to realize oh yeah I don't I don't know
and it's like yeah so you can't go to the blank
page yet because you don't know but learning that
you don't know is just as helpful because now what
holes need to be filled before you get to the page
when a writer is outlining a screenplay does that
mean they are creating structure at the same time
yes exactly that's exactly what that means they
should be looking to understand what scenes make
up my normal and when I say normal that means
the everyday life of these characters whether
the cameras showed up or not like we're all living
our normal lives every day so your characters are
people who are doing whatever it is they do for
an action film that means we're probably going to
open in action because in their normal lives
they're already a police officer firefighter
ex-military whatever it is they are so now you're
asking yourself in the outline what scenes am I
using to show my character's normal life until we
get to the inciting incident which is the thing
that's going to crash into that normal life create
change therefore causing a goal or a problem so
you have to ask yourself what do those scenes look
like what's that sequence of the inciting incident
what is the inciting incident how does it make
my protagonists feel all of these great questions
and then you're going to start to figure out well
what is the debate is there a debate do they have
to decide to go on this journey or is it so urgent
that no matter what they're going on the journey
then you have to fix so you have to figure out
what do those scenes look like because that
that there being a debate what's the debate who
are they debating with where are they debating
why are they debating you get to figure all of
that out so the same is true throughout the entire
screenplay but in the outline you're putting
in all of the structure all of those big beats
but asking yourself what are the scenes how do I
visually show this beat because a million people
can probably tell you the inciting incident is a
car crash great where were they going what were
they doing who else is in the car where did the
car crash happen did the ambulance come or did
they stay there by themselves and pass away or did
they end up getting out did random people on the
side of the road come pull them out like what is
the scene and so in the outline you get to start
asking yourself what those scenes are and putting
them down not in screenplay format but just
the information of they were driving their
child to the nursery when they got hit by
a a semi auto semi truck whatever that
came through the light and then we cut to
the jaws of life getting them out that's the
information you need in your outline so that when
you get to your screenplay you can write it all
beautifully however it is you're going to write it
well if we take something maybe that's
less dramatic so if we go back to our
sort of metaphorical pam character who's like this
office administrator everybody needs her now she's
remote working her phone is buzzing all the time
she has no separation between her job and her her
life but then maybe the inciting incident because
she's going to find this other job which she'll
moonlight during office hours and they won't
know it because she'll have a second computer
maybe she meets a woman in a store and they just
have a fun exchange talking and she says what do
you do and she says oh I'm an office administrator
and the other woman does these surveys and she's
kind of fascinating there's something a little
interesting about her so she goes hey give me your
email and all so then maybe that's where and she
sees this woman and she's kind of intrigued by her
because she she's just different pam always does
the thing and this woman's a little bit rebellious
a little bit interesting and maybe that's the
the incident yeah it's not the jaws of life
but it's something yeah something is changing her
normal her normal is I'm working at home from zoom
every single day I'm answering the calls and I
have got to get dressed from here up so that I
can be present when they need me blah blah blah
blah today for lunch I decided to go for a walk
and while I'm on that walk because I go
into the store to buy my lunch or whatever
I meet this person that person just changed
her life so that's the inciting incident
and that small information is what's in
your outline then you'll flesh that out to
actually be full scenes and however it is you
describe them in the action and the dialogue
and blah blah that's the screenplay but in
the outline you say pam's working from her
desk all the time she's dressed from here on up
blah blah blah she's always answering the phone
and today she decided to go for a
walk for lunch and she bumps into
insert person right that's what you would have in
your outline okay so that would be the inciting
incident if it wasn't as dramatic where there
was a full action yeah the inciting incident can
be the smallest thing like comedies don't have
huge inciting incidents romantic comedies have
a breakup or meeting the other person or whatever
it is but whatever that thing is it's different
because if it's not different why am I here I
don't I'm not here to watch people's everyday
lives I have my own life I can go watch my
friends lives what I mean I'm here because
something is changing for them and I now
need to watch them to struggle through it
grow through it whatever is going to happen on
that journey that's why I'm here so there has
to be an inciting incident something has to come
in and make change cause problems cause a goal
that needs to be achieved what is your process for
teaching screenplay structure yeah so I start with
this great the screenplay I start with the pixar
formula from the pixar formula I go into character
work I am someone in my own time who likes to
psychoanalyze things I'm always asking people why
how what what happened to you and so we do some
work like that for the characters the more that
you understand people the more you can understand
your characters who are people so in my class
which may make some people uncomfortable but in my
class we talk about ourselves a lot we're doing a
lot of inner work because my class is also about
fighting writer's block and in my opinion writer's
block comes from lack of confidence and lack of
preparation so we spend a lot of time talking
about confidence talking about what our fears
are what our flaws are what our wants are what's
standing in the way of those wants why because
that's what's happening for your characters what
do they want what do they need what's standing in
the way of that what are they what are they afraid
of what are their flaws that are going to get in
the way of them getting the thing that they want
so if you start to understand how your own life
the life of your tribe members I call my classes
tribes the life of your tribe members if you start
to understand why they do the things they do then
you start to understand characters a little bit
more and now your characters can be more authentic
in their journey because oftentimes I can feel
the writer making characters do things versus it
feeling like an actual decision that the character
would make so we spend some time on characters
so let's say that's week two that's actually just
what I did on a couple of days ago week two that
was last night it was just last night it's hard
to keep up with time these days it's all one
big thing then we start to talk about goal
setting because every single story is about
your protagonist solving a problem reaching a goal
that's why we are here so we have to figure out
what's the best goal for them to reach or who's
the best character for that goal depending upon
which one you begin with and then we start
talking about now how are they physically
going to achieve it because again going back to
they need to save the world well that's general
what are they going to do how are they going to
save it and start asking ourselves well what are
the things that get in the way so in the fourth
week we start talking about the complications
we started talking about the stakes in in
week three we also talk about world building
because every single story you have to teach
us the rules of that world if it's just regular
old present-day earth something that we see in
the first three minutes are gonna tell me that
that's what it is so you're still teaching me if
it's a new industry like I love to use devil the
devil wears prada I'm not in the fashion industry
so you have to teach me how it works here so they
open up by showing me how all the other women
are nicely dressed and our protagonist is not
they show us by when she gets into that office
how everyone is looking at her judging her
and then when meryl streep's character is going
to show up everybody it's chaotic because they're
trying to make sure they get in line I'm learning
about this industry I'm learning about what the
rules are here even if there's not much being said
out loud so we talk about that and especially if
you're doing something that's science fiction
fantasy supernatural horror then there are rules
you have to set up I need to know candyman comes
when I say it how many times because if not then
I don't have the suspense now if I see a person
standing in the mirror and they only say it twice
should I be afraid because I don't know how many
times they're supposed to say it if I understand
they have to say it five times I don't even
remember if it's five or three but they have to
say it x amount of times and now I know when she
gets on number four that I should be on the edge
of my seat but I don't know that if you haven't
given me the information so we talk about world
building and then in the last week that's when we
finally start talking about outlining because I
want people to know there's not one way to do it
you can do it a million different ways so I show
them different examples of how you can outline but
all of those things that we're learning basically
break into those large beats and let me be
specific about those beats because I've said them
said that word a lot but I'm talking specifically
about the normal the inciting incident the goal
or the problem getting into act two knowing what
your midpoint is knowing what your rock bottom is
knowing what your point of no return is which
some people kind of mix into that rock bottom
midpoint place it basically just means we get to
a place where something changes so much that our
character has to change tactics that's just all it
means everybody gives it a different word but then
we got to get up to our climax which is your
highest point when your bad guy is going to
meet your good guy or your character is going
to meet their problem head on and then we get
to come down to the resolution where we say what
have they won because they succeeded or what did
they lose because they didn't yet throughout that
entire journey we were following them emotionally
so even if they didn't succeed we still feel
satisfaction with the story so all of those beats
are what I mean when I'm saying structure
all of those beats fit into your act one
act two and act three and so I utilize those
different weeks to talk about those different
elements because they all
break into those big beats
and how can you tell and I realize this is very
specific and we don't have something to workshop
but just vaguely when someone is really forcing an
action from their character it can be because the
evidence is just not on the page or the evidence
is on the page and your character isn't doing
what you've told us that they do so if you've said
this is a really shy character every single thing
you've shown us is that they're shy and then on
page 15 they stand on top of a table and dance
what that's not who you told me this person was so
unless you showed me something that motivated this
then now I know you just needed her on a table
dancing because of whatever else is going to
happen in the screenplay not because she would get
on that table and dance I see okay yeah so we're
missing what would ever cause that if this was
truly what the characters would do okay yeah so
we're missing that so either it's just not there
at all or it's the opposite of what you told us
yeah and so it's like we know that you needed
this character to end up in jail because
now the sun has to avenge whatever's going
on with with the parent being in jail
but it isn't set up that our character would have
even done any of those things that they did to be
in jail so now I know you're just forcing them
into this position because of what you need to
happen from that so it's like you got to set
me up with the information so I can believe it
because if I don't believe it then now now the
stakes aren't as high now you just start to
lose me as a as an audience member yeah so it's
just like I need the evidence so that's a lot
of what i'll write in my notes I don't there's
no evidence of this this doesn't ring true like
where did this happen when do we meet that well
you said on page this that this is how they feel
but on page this they feel this way what motivated
that change where where was that because maybe I
missed it I probably didn't but maybe I missed it
but if I didn't if I didn't miss it then now it's
missing and you can figure out how to make that
connection because everything is cause and effect
people are cause and effect if I have an argument
in this room when I walk into that room my energy
is gonna be different if I had not had an
argument in this room so the same thing is
true about your characters why are they doing the
stuff that they're doing what happened on the page
to show me that motivates any of their decisions
how does a writer introduce a protagonist
in a way that makes the viewer or the reader want
to follow that character yeah good question I
actually did an entire workshop on how do I and
I call them how the f all of my workshops are
in the what the f workshop series so this
particular workshop was how the f do I
introduce my protagonist and there are a million
ways to do it but what we're looking for is what
information are you going to give me about them
in their normal life that makes me like them or
relate to them I don't have to do both it's 20
21 so I don't have to like the character they
can be totally unlikable but something about
them has to be I have to be able to relate to
in order to care enough and invest in them on
this journey so I use the word social proof
and basically what that means is prove to
me going back to the evidence prove to me
who they are on the page whether that means
we're receiving information from someone else
or we're watching them do the thing because just
like regular human beings you can only take what
they say about themselves with a grain of salt so
I can sit here and go I'm an expert I'm an expert
I'm an expert but unless you actually hear me
giving my expertise on something or you hear from
someone else who you trust who says Shannan
is an expert then you're probably gonna say
I'm not one so on the page you have to then
show us that your characters are whoever it
is you want us to believe that they are so one of
my favorite examples is using scandal we open up
scandal hearing from two other people talk about
olivia pope one of them is the trusted source
the other one is the fish out of water who already
has some kind of admiration for olivia pope
so as we're hearing them talk about olivia they're
putting her on this pedestal and now we are
therefore intrigued to go well who's this olivia
I want to know her she seems cool and then in the
next scene olivia now has to live up to the thing
that we just heard so now you have to show us in
action they could have gone to the next scene and
olivia was just sitting there having a meeting
talking on the phone to herself but instead they
put her in a situation to show her social proof
and doing her job and so hearing from those other
people first and then seeing her actually do the
thing is what made us want to journey with olivia
pope so the same is true for your characters there
is no particular kind of formula but what I
will say is you got about five to seven minutes
to get me engaged with your protagonist some
stories won't start with the protagonist which
is fine but that means if it didn't start with the
protagonists and then we meet them you have less
time to get me to like or relate to them because
I'm already x amount of minutes into your film
so for example I'm teaching from armageddon now we
don't meet harry stamper I think a snapper until
like page 10 which means we're we've been here
for 10 minutes already because we got our exciting
incident on page two so that means the urgency
is already there they're already making up a plan
by the time we meet harry I only get like
three pages to really understand who he is
and jump into action with him to decide to invest
in him so now you have even less time because I'm
already 10 minutes into it but either way whatever
it is I see them doing first so you can't be
generic about that like oftentimes I
will read a screenplay and it's just
oh such and such woman who's beautiful is cooking
breakfast and it just seems like she's cooking
breakfast because she needs busy work in the
kitchen not because cooking breakfast teaches us
anything about her is she cooking breakfast
because she's a stay-at-home mom and she's in her
pajamas and she has to get up early even though
she's going to be at home but because she's got
to get husband out she's got to get kids out and
she's getting it done or is she career woman who's
cooking breakfast so she doesn't really have much
time because she's on the phone at the same time
she's just trying to get something in and it's a
smoothie and she's running out or is this saturday
the only day that she gets to relax and she's
making brunch because her girlfriends are coming
over like what does it mean and what am I learning
about this person as they're cooking eggs because
if not they could be doing something else what I
mean so every single piece of information that I
get in those first five to seven minutes are gonna
help me know who they are and that's prime real
estate and a lot of people pass through that prime
real estate by doing the uncle such and such thing
talking about all this other stuff that does not
matter meanwhile all I got about my protagonist
was beautiful in cooking eggs why am I investing
in her what how is that interesting why would any
actor who reads it say I have got to play her so
you're trying to give me some information that's
gonna give me a reason to invest in the rest
of their journey and you only get a very short
amount of time okay so if something doesn't
happen within a five to seven minute minute
mark to show me why I should care about the
scene so then if we have this woman cooking
these eggs and then maybe there's a knock at
the door and it's some door-to-door salesman
so we think and it turns out it's really a private
investigator and they're saying I have something
for you and her life is about to change in that
moment and she finds out that her life and what
she thought it was wasn't really that but we
don't know in that moment so everything seems
calm and wonderful and she's beautiful and she has
this nice kitchen but then the knock at the door
is going to be what's going to upset the apple
cart yes but I want to make sure that we separate
the two things that that upset of the apple cart
can happen 15 pages in it can happen 17 pages in
everything that I'm getting up until that upset is
what's making me invest in her why do I care that
her life is going to change if I haven't learned
anything about her life other than the fact that
she cooks eggs what information are you gonna give
me does she have a child that she's caring for
that they have a really great relationship
with does she have a husband that she has
a bad relationship with and she's just today's
the day they're supposed to go to therap therapy
and she just really wants it to go well and
then this thing comes in and interrupts that
so what information am I getting about this
person's everyday life that's already worth
investing in so that when the upset comes I too
can be upset like no she really needs to go to
therapy today she doesn't have time to deal with
this door-to-door guy or no her sleeping child
is in the other room and she tried so hard to
have children and she finally has one and then
here comes this person and are they posing a
threat to the child that's in the other room
and again none of this has anything to do with
eggs so the question is do we need to open with
her cooking eggs like what does that mean for
her as a character or maybe it means everything
because she's really a chef in another life
but because she decided to be a stay-at-home
mom blah blah blah or maybe it means I'm always
going to make sure my husband's eggs are great
we argue every morning but these eggs matter today
because we have therapy later and I want him to be
happy when he gets to therapy now all of that
stuff is making me invest in her so when the
person comes and knocks on the door I understand
no no no we don't need this interruption like
we don't need this to happen how can you
explain smart goals for your protagonist yeah
good question so I actually do a series called
story elements on my youtube channel and one of
them is on goals and I talk about smart goals so
smart goals is an acronym for specific measurable
attainable relevant and time-bound okay and
smart goals actually was not created for story
but it works so I have adapted it from like a
business model to use it to teach my students
how to make goals for their protagonists so
specific means we need to know what it is period
we need to know what they're trying to achieve so
that we can track the progress or regress of it
how will we know that they were successful if we
don't know what they were looking for in the first
place so your goal needs to be specific the second
one is measurable so that again goes back to being
able to track it we need to know are they getting
closer to it or farther from it which is why
I always talk about your external goal being
the personification of the internal goal so if
someone's goal is to not grieve anymore how do I
track that what does that look like and if you can
attach grieving to something external or not
grieving to something external then we'll know
that when they reach that external thing then
they reach the goal and their grief has probably
subsided the third one is attainable which means
going back to social proof you have to prove to me
that my protagonist has the skills to be able to
attain this goal because if not then I'm not going
to believe that they can do it or if it's a comedy
then you're going to show me that they don't
have the skills to attain this goal which means
they're either going to do a really bad job of it
or they're going to have to learn along the way
or even in a drama I don't have those skills so
I have to learn those skills along the way and so
now it's probably going to be during your debate
time or somewhere in your journey in your second
act where they actually have to learn those skills
the fourth one is relevant and I like this one
because this one kind of starts to attach that
internal thing to the external thing it's like
why does this thing matter to this particular
protagonist so that goes back to choosing the
protagonist for the goal having the goal for the
protagonist so if you can make it relevant
then we will invest more we will empathize
more and the last one is time-bound and not
every single story is going to have something
time-bound but it's basically your ticking
clock if this if there's a state of urgency
if like an armageddon you have 18 days before the
world explodes then we understand that suspense
is that tension is going to stay there it's
like oh my god we only have 18 days and now
we have 12 and now we have 50 however many days so
adding a ticking clock depending upon your story
will always heighten the stakes so if nothing
else you need specific measurable attainable
and relevant and depending upon what your
story is you can then add a ticking clock
how else can I write a three-dimensional character
good question so getting into the stuff of the
character is where that dimension is going to
come from people are complex we're not all good
we're not all bad we all have wants we all have
needs we all have flaws we all have skills even
before the inciting incident happens so if you
can figure out what those things are then you will
figure out what's motivating your character I gave
this example that I am the youngest of six girls
but the closest one in age to me is six years
older than I am which would mean that at age
six she's 12. we don't play the same so we're not
interacting in the same way when I'm 12 she's 18.
we don't play the same so we're not interacting
in the same way because she's 18 she's graduating
from high school so now I'm in at home by
myself for another six years so even though
I have five older siblings I spent a lot of
time alone so therefore I have an only child
kind of experience just as much as I have a
youngest child experience that shows up in my life
I am an introverted extrovert a lot of people know
me as the life of a party I have a big personality
but I love being alone I problem solve
alone I do a lot of stuff by myself
because my history taught me to be able to be
okay with that good or bad so understanding
those things about your characters will let why
they do the things they do so there may be people
who say well Shannan well why didn't you call me
on saturday we could have hung out because they
don't understand that Shannan just likes to sit at
home and be by herself because she's used to that
that person may take it personally oh well that's
an offense towards me you don't think that we're
really good friends and blah blah blah blah but
it's like no it really has nothing to do with you
and everything to do with me and the same
thing is true for your characters they are
acting and reacting because of who they
are where they're from an immigrant is
not having the same experience in america
as an american born person period if that
depending upon the kind of story you're telling
you can now infuse your story with that stuff
the same thing is culturally as a black person
there are things that are going to happen in my
house that may not happen in someone else's so you
have to then take that and figure out how you can
color in the lines of your story with this
cultural stuff that makes it authentic for them
but the only way you can do that is if you really
take the time out to know who your characters are
and know why they're making the decisions they're
making and now you can get three-dimensional
people the other thing is it's 2021 so we're
now doing the same thing for our antagonist
our antagonists get to be three-dimensional
now we're no longer in the jack nicholson
joker time we're in the heath ledger and the
joaquin phoenix joker time we're in the killmonger
time where we understand our antagonists just
as much as we understand our protagonists
which leaves us as an audience fighting with those
themes and trying to figure out who's and who's
wrong and now there's discussion happening when
people go home but that only happens when you
take the time to dimensionalize your antagonist
understand what their plan is understand what
they want what motivates them which is usually
the opposite of your protagonist or the same
like if it's a sports movie it's the same we both
want to win if it's some kind of action film then
it's usually the opposite the antagonist wants to
kill people the protagonist doesn't want them to
those are the reasons that they are in
competition with each other and I've said
before if we change the pov of the story then your
antagonist should easily become your protagonist
your protagonist is the antagonist antagonist
because that antagonist does not exist because
your protagonists exist that was already a
person who was already planning to kill people
you came in and became a complication for that
person they didn't start killing people because
you exist they were already a murderer and as
a police officer you came in and you decided
to to muddy it up so if we were telling
the story from the killer's point of view
then now that would be our protagonist and
they'd both be dimensionalized enough to put us
in the middle of it because they're stories about
vigilantes they're murderers but they're doing it
for a reason we understand their reasoning and
sometimes we're on their side for it so if you
give us if you do the work because some of that
work you're gonna do is not gonna end up on the
page but it's still going to dictate some of the
choices you make for those characters on the page
what are the elements of story that have to
happen in act two oh good question so in act
2 some people call this the fun and games place
I call it the trial and error place I look at it
like this is your recipe this is your I want
to bake a cake how step one do this step two
do this so in act two we're actually watching the
character try to achieve the goal successfully or
unsuccessfully so being able to see them actually
take physical steps towards doing that thing is
what we're watching now we're going to start
putting in the complications and I like to call
it complications and not conflict because people
see conflict and they go just add some negative
something but a complication is something that's
very specific to stand in the way of the goal
so they're going to start coming in contact
with things that are hindering them from getting
what they need things that are redirecting them
things that are causing them to hit rock bottom
and then you need a midpoint and your midpoint
sounds like what it is happens kind of in the
middle of your story doesn't have to literally be
on page 45 of the 90 pages but it's gonna happen
somewhere around there and it basically
means that something big enough happens
to cause that redirection either I'm gonna
hit rock bottom or I have a false victory
or I receive some information that changes my
goal so I believe I gave this example I've given
this example before because it's the easiest one
for me if my goal was to find my kidnapped child
at the midpoint i'd find out that my kidnapped
child has already been killed that doesn't mean
the story is over though because we're only at
the midpoint that means my my goal has to change
so now my goal is not to find my child my goal
is to find the killer to get revenge to get
justice and so for the rest of the screenplay
we're gonna watch the the parent do that
instead of looking after the child so the
goal changes something causes a redirection
and then some people look at the climax as what
happens at the end of act two some people look at
it as what happens at the beginning of act three
either way it's in the same place in my opinion so
you're also going to be getting your character
up to the point where they actually are
face to face with that goal or face to face
with that antagonist so they can win or lose
so those are the biggest beats they need that
trial and error time or fun and games time
or steps to their recipe time they need those
complications that get in the way of that
so they can grow so they can redirect they
need that big moment whatever that midpoint is
that causes a new goal makes them redirect makes
them hit rock bottom so someone has to come in and
re-motivate them now your mentor character gets to
come in and give a speech or whatever and keep get
them going if you're watching an episode of grey's
anatomy that's the moment where it's like I found
the new cure at first we thought we'd never be
able to do this surgery oh no we didn't do well
I found this new thing and now for the rest of the
episode they're gonna do the new thing until they
win or lose or save the patient or not save the
patient and then you'll go up to the climax which
is where they save the patient or not save the
patient so those are the beats that you're looking
for in act two so if we used our pam from the
office and so she's at home doing the zoom she's
already now met this woman at a store who says
email me I've got this really cool job if you want
to make some extra money and pam is already doing
the job by act two maybe okay it depends on what
the goal of the episode is so if we're looking
at meeting this woman as the inciting incident
the problem can be deciding to call her or not
and if that's the pro if that's the goal deciding
to call her then the journey is going to be the
decision now she's going to have to I don't know
what she's doing to figure out whether she should
make this call or not but that may mean that
everything we're watching in her normal every day
is telling her I need a change I need a new thing
that motivates the call because it can be the end
of the episode where she finally makes the call
or it could be that I already know I'm gonna
call I've said I was gonna call so that means
we're gonna watch her call we're going to watch
her get set up with the new job we're going to
watch her do all of that in the second act where
she figures out what it is and then again seeing
how that may cause friction with her current job
so it really again is always going to depend on
what's the intended goal is is the pilot let's
say this is her this is the pilot is the pilot
about her choosing to go into this nefarious
work or is the pilot about I admit it what are
the repercussions of it okay so something
would have to happen so let's say so and
the stuff that was happening for her to decide
what happened in act one no that's going to be
act two okay and only because we're talking
about television now and television if it's
in television we need that inciting incident by
the end of act one so now your act two is gonna
be all the stuff that yeah I decided to take the
job I didn't decide to take the job this is why
this is what's happening with my other job and
then in act three you resolve and and depending
upon what the goal was if she's choosing to take
the job then in act three we finally hear her say
I'm gonna take the job if it was no I've chosen
this job and the problem is trying to balance
then by the end of act three we'll know what the
rest of the season is going to look like because
we just saw how this balance works or doesn't work
or maybe she didn't find out that it was nefarious
until the climax of the episode so in act 3 she
has to decide to continue even though she knows
that it's nefarious so it can go a million ways
but basically whatever that goal is that we get
by the end of act one when that inciting incident
happens she meets pam at the end of act one
pam says call me and act two we're gonna either
see her call and then get on board it or decide
to call which means now we have to see well what
motivates that because if this is so far out of
her life she would never do something like this
then that means whatever's happening during this
day in this episode is the stuff that's pushing
her to finally make the call okay so maybe she
gets a text in the middle of the night and it's
urgent and they've got to fax something overseas
and hey I'm really sorry to bother you I know
you're sleeping but this needs to happen asap
and then maybe she sees the webcam light come
on on her work computer and she realizes there's
like some type of a snooping software and it's
recording her and and it knows that she took
like a 10 minute walk around the block and she
wasn't at her computer and so she's now feeling
trapped by this job and she says okay I might
email this interesting lady and the interesting
lady gets back to her like midnight hey here
it is and this is what you do here's a link
and she goes maybe she has a glass of
wine and she decides to apply for the job
and now she's giving reviews on lingerie it's not
horrible it's like something where yeah because if
we're saying that it's in the tone of the office
and that means it's a half hour single camera
so it's going to be kind of like kind of funny
may have small things happen here and there that
could be a little darker but that means we're
talking about three act structure and we're
talking about half hours so we don't have a lot
of time so it can be something that simple that I
got back I got this card oh i'd never do that and
now I'm sleeping and enjoying myself and here come
these people saying they need this facts and this
thing and that thing and I just want something new
all i'll make the call let's do something new okay
and so and then in act three something entirely
different is going to happen possibly depending
upon what happened in your act two since it's all
cause and effect but because we're talking about
television and because we're talking about the
pilot by the time we get to the end of act three
we need to understand what the series is about so
we need to know that she has decided to do this
and either we already know it's nefarious or we
don't so that's what we're gonna find out in the
series or we realize it's getting in the way of
her current job and so we're going to watch her
try to balance it throughout so we'll we'll
need that information so sometimes in pilots
usually when it's kind of like a whodunit kind of
thing and a half hour single camera comedy they
usually tie up things with a pretty decent bow
at the end of the episodes but if we're talking
about one-hour dramas if we're talking about
a whodunit kind of limited series thing then
at the end of every episode you're going to give
me some new information so yes something new is
going to happen so that i'll come back to the
next episode and that new information might be
it wasn't who you thought it was or this is a new
person's doing something sneaky or whatever it is
yeah what mistakes do writers make in act
2 that end up ruining their screenplay yeah
this is where they don't know structure this
is where they haven't figured out what their
story was before they got to the page because
this is where uncle such and such shows up
this is where this is the goal this is
the story and the writer is doing this
because they don't know what the goal or the
story is or they don't know how to get to z from a
and maybe it's because they're just a new
writer so they really just don't know how
or they don't understand structure so they're
doing all of these other things to get to z
but none of those things connect going back to
cause and effect none of those things connect
so that happens quite often and I think that's
the biggest thing sometimes there is no midpoint
and depending upon what kind of story it is what
the tone is what the genre is the midpoint doesn't
have to be something huge but it's bigger than
your other trials and tribulations so sometimes
people are missing that thing that gets us over
the hump because once we get into act two and
you get into those those trials and tribulations
if it's take a step fail take a step fail take
a step fail by the time they're doing that the
fourth time I'm no longer invested what I mean I
need something that's going to change this thing
to get us going in the story so it goes back to
having that friend or cousin who's really great at
telling stories they know how to hook us in make
us think that this one thing is happening and then
take us to the next thing so that midpoint kind of
gets us over that hump of they've been
trying and failing or trying and succeeding
and here's something that's going to change
this whole thing for us so that the pacing can
kind of start to rev up and we can get to the
climax so a lot of times that's missing also
the climax is missing but more so in television
pilots that I read than in features it seems
like future writers kind of understand a little
bit more that there needs to be this high point
in tv because people are thinking about the series
and if you're writing a pilot then you're creating
a world and characters that people can be invested
in they sometimes forget about the structure of it
and forget that yeah but we're still telling
a story so I need them I need we got to get up
and so a lot of times that's missing and so if
you're writing a half hour single camera comedy
that means or a dramedy then you have three acts
so your climax is gonna happen at the end of act
two or at the top of act three depending upon how
you write it if you're doing a one hour drama and
let's just stay in the five act place because
there's a four act that exists in the six act
whatever let's stay in the five act place then
it's going to happen at the end of act four or top
of act five depending upon how you write it so a
lot of the times in tv there's just it never makes
it to a peak it just kind of stays here the whole
time and no matter what stories you're telling
pilots features even if you're writing a spec and
you're doing an episode of something we're looking
for stories to do this we're on a roller coaster
so we don't want to spend our whole time like
this we don't want to spend our whole time like
this we don't want to spend the whole time like
that we have to have all of it happening if not
it's not a fun ride and no one wants to get on it
and so uncle gus's method would be he would
just be telling too much sort of sidebar detail
that we don't need whereas the other
person at the let's say the family barbecue
they have like a a b and c a very clear point
very clear points very clear path and by the time
uncle gus is done and you ask uncle gus so what
happened he probably wouldn't even tell you the
same story if you asked again because he's just
talking about everything and doesn't know his his
point his end goal or he gets to the end goal but
we're all lost because none of the stuff between
when he started in the end goal made any sense
because they're not connected everything has to
be connected and the other cousin knows how to
make a connect to b connect to c connect to d
uncle gus is saying a g e m and it's like
wait but what happened to b and c and d
I got missing something like give me this other
information and he's cracking himself up no one
else is laughing because we missed the joke what I
mean yes that kind of stuff that starts happening
do writers get confused with subplot versus plot
how do we know the difference yeah I'm going to
assume that if you're saying subplot that you
mean different story lines and that's the way
that I kind of like to talk about it and I don't
think I've seen too many people get confused with
it but not really knowing how to use them and make
them impactful for each other so when I describe
sub characters I describe them as characters
who are helping or hindering the protagonist's
goal we only care about these sub characters
because they are pushing the a story forward
that doesn't mean that those characters don't also
have their own storylines because they're people
and they should be doing things other than walking
around behind your protagonist all day however
the point of their stories is to eventually
crash into the a story eventually complicate
the a story eventually help the a story even if
they look like they're going this for this way
at some point they're gonna connect and so I think
some people miss that and they will then start to
write an entirely different story for the b story
that has absolutely nothing to do with the a story
and now we're watching these two stories go but
they're not connected so going back to our family
reunion if I were to come to your family reunion
I expect to meet your cousins not your neighbor's
cousins so those sub characters are here because
they're important to this protagonist they're
not other random people in the world those random
people weren't invited to the barbecue the people
who are here the people who are helping or hurting
informing helping complicating what's going
on with the protagonists so we only care about
them because of their proxy their proximity to
the protagonist so I think people don't understand
that and they just say oh my subplot or my b story
is just another story it's like no thematically
they tie plot wise they tie something about them
connects them all and a great example of that is
crash the crash because there are 50 million main
characters but they're all dealing with the same
kind of themes and they all eventually connect
so spoiler alert they all eventually get you to
this dead kid who is the brother of one of those
people who was killed by one of the other people
so it all starts to connect when we first start to
watch it we're like why do we need to be following
all these people what is what is going on but it's
because their world is smaller than we think it is
they are all in the same world and they will all
affect that a story so in that particular film
haven't seen it in a little while but I wouldn't
say there's a standout protagonist unless
we'll say it's don cheadle's character who is
the detective maybe but instead it seems like we
just have a lot of main characters and they each
have their own story lines but the a plot is
what happened to this this boy because we open up
with learning that someone died so the main plot
is what happened to this boy and then we go into
all of these other stories to eventually come back
to oh that's what happened but then beyond that
the themes are about how we're all just people
regardless of our differences so it talks a lot
about race and religion and all these other
things so each of those groups of people is
dealing with that theme on their own level so that
still connects them they're they're not random
stories that are being told they're all connected
so if people can understand that about subplot or
like I like to call them story lines or a story b
story c story e d story however many story lines
you're going to have they all have to connect and
they all have to push your a story forward even if
when they first start it seems like it has nothing
to do with that eventually it all has to come back
to this one thing or at least thematically tie
and the theme is usually again going to be shown
in your a story so that means all of the other
storylines are still going to thematically tie
into them well let's take this family barbecue
so let's say everybody's happy everything's
wonderful and then there's another scene where
there's a man and maybe a beat-up vehicle
who's delivering something and it's his personal
vehicle and he's stressing out he's in traffic
and people are cutting him off whatever and he's
trying to be a decent driver but he finally gets
there and he's sweating and he unloads this
cake for this barbecue and when he delivers it
he finds out that one of the children there
that's actually his kid and the wife and he
had been estranged for years and now this happy
moment is awful because all the memories have come
back and he hasn't seen the sun in years because
it was too it was too difficult yeah and so now
he's this subplot has now come into the
main plot exactly okay okay and so then
how so then how long does this sub character stay
at that barbecue yeah it depends on your story
going back to what's the goal is the goal for
him to have the realization of this was my family
because if so then that's the end of the movie
everything got us to the moment that he arrived
if the story is about working on getting my
family back or working on rekindling with
my son or whatever that was then it could be the
inciting incident that he shows up with the cake
it could be the midpoint that he shows up with
the cake so we've been seeing him he had his
goal I need to deliver this cake we're watching
up until the midpoint everything that he's trying
to do to deliver the cake I don't know what's
happening with the other family but they have
their own goals and whatever they're doing
preparing for the barbecue whatever they're doing
or attending the barbecue and dealing with family
drama because they're already talking about
her ex-husband and blah blah blah that kind
of thing so when he shows up at the midpoint
now things are redirected so what's happening
for the rest of the time is it stay here and
work it out because this is the scene it's it's
pandemic so people aren't doing a lot of different
locations and blah blah blah so do we
stay here and work out the whole thing
or does that end the barbecue scene and now we go
into the rest of life as he's trying to rekindle
the relationship so depending upon what that
goal is then how long this barbecue thing needs
to happen or this journey to the barbecue in the
first place and then what scenes we need after
that for him to actually reach his goal and if
you've done your work of making the goal relevant
while he's preparing this cake while he's driving
through traffic while he's doing blah blah blah we
will learn that there is a loneliness there we
will learn that there is a like maybe we don't
get want to give it away that he lost his child
whatever that stuff is but we're getting some
information to know that there's something he's
missing something that he's needing something
he's given up on maybe it's because people are
calling as he's driving and he's I don't want to
talk about it man blah blah whatever that is we'll
start to know something else is going on here so
that when he arrives with that cake and he gets
out of the car and stops short yeah no one has to
say anything we know because we've been given the
evidence that something's going on with him and
we've been given the evidence at the barbecue as
she's been setting up and oh he's of this and he's
that and we've been hearing the stuff it hasn't
been like the a story because it wasn't yet but
now that these two things have collided they'll
make one storyline and we'll go on from there
how many subplots should a movie have or a tv show
have yeah so there isn't necessarily a set amount
but what I will say is your a story is going to
be in every single one of your acts fully out
some movies will only have an a story if you have
a b story it's now still all of the same amount of
beats but shorter so if your a story is this long
your b story might be that long your c story and d
story and e story all get shorter but they're
still full story lines which means they have their
own goals their own complications climaxes etc in
a television show you're usually only gonna have
maybe about three per episode even if you have six
or seven characters like if you watch this is us
something's gonna be going on with one of
the big three something's gonna be going
on with mom and dad in the past and then
we may also be watching something else
maybe in a show like brothers and sisters there
were five kids and a mom so maybe we're definitely
gonna have at least three story lines but there
might be a fourth small nugget of something
that's giving us breadcrumbs from something
bigger that's going to happen down the road
what I will say is in features it's good to have
at least more than one storyline depending on the
genre most horror movies have one storyline stay
alive protagonist that's it they're also usually
only 75 minutes long so we don't really have
time to be following up and other people and
whatever else is going on we're just trying to
stay in this one little thing but other than
that it's good to have a b story because you
want to break up the monotony of the a story
because again once we get into the second act it's
about reaching that goal and if I'm just if every
single page is about what this one person is doing
that can become monotonous it becomes like get
there or don't get there we start to get a little
impatient so if you have something to break it up
with another storyline another full story line
then that can kind of help keep the pacing up
I've seen it a lot in love stories a lot of
love stories will just have the love but how
much can we take together not together together
not together together not together it's like
do they have anything else that they can be doing
like what's going on in their personal lives that
can be a b and a c story what I mean what's
going on with mom that that can thematically
tie to what's happening with them that we can be
watching because if not then we can start to get
disinterested by the redundancy because it's a
relationship how much can they really go through
even if it's a new piece of conflict it still ends
in the same thing be together or don't so if we
keep watching them do this for 40 minutes I mean
that we need to break that up a little bit so it's
always good to have another but in general there
isn't a standard I think that you can figure out
if you if you've gotten too many of them if things
start to get a little messy and you can't really
follow the story lines like even if you look at
a marvel film at the avengers the avengers has
all of the peop all of the superheroes there but
we're not following each of them separately in all
the things that they're doing we may be following
them as a group and then following one or two of
them who may be doing something separately and
the others are just there for support in this
particular movie and that's okay so you want
to definitely make sure that it doesn't become
too much like if you look at at crash that was I
don't know how many people that was but there was
a lot of story lines but they were simple enough
simple and thematic so each time we came to them
we were kind of mirroring whatever just happened
with the other group of people on their side of
town or getting them closer to meeting one of
the other group of people so it worked for them
so that's why again it's everything is going
to come down to what's best for your story
so you have to be paying attention to that pacing
and am I spending enough time to understand what
the storyline is or am I just dropping a couple
of people every now and again which now confuses
us so instead of it breaking up the monotony
it's confusing us and we have more questions
so you just have to again find another pair of
eyes if you can't figure it out hire a script
consultant like myself there are plenty of us
out there or have someone who understands story
at least to read it to see how it's making
them feel and what information they're missing
so with this family barbecue story if we have
this dad that's now bringing this cake and now
the rest of the family is just stunned that he's
doing this job and that he's there and that he's
actually shown himself maybe there were calls that
say don't come by anymore who knows what happened
if we were to add another character it would
somehow have to make it in it can't just be the
random guy at the bar that he goes pounds a drink
and he goes hey man slow down what's wrong and
oh I can't talk about it somehow that guy at the
bar has to be part of the story he can't just be
I mean again every sub-character has their own
role to play meeting a guy in a bar doesn't have
to become a storyline okay that sub-character can
just be the person in the bar that had some kind
of conversation with our actual character that
motivated or changed them to go do something
okay so that person doesn't have to become a
storyline that person can just be a guy in the bar
who said whatever but whatever it is he said had
to have changed our character because if not then
we don't need this conversation we don't need
this bar we don't need this location we need to
pay for these people or any of that right okay so
that so that's going to be the difference but if
I watched guy at bar at home and then watch guy at
bar get to the bar then I watch guy at bar drive
away from the bar then now I'm asking myself okay
what does this guy bar have to do with any of this
because now I'm watching their life from their
point of view so does guy from barr end up being
her new boyfriend so he didn't know that when they
were sitting next to each other these two men when
they're talking about the situation and gaia bar
is like you should go get your family back and now
guy with cake shows up at the barbecue and then
guy with bar a guy from the bar drives up what are
you doing here getting my family back oh that's
my girl now we've got something going on now these
story lines are connecting I was actually thinking
that the guy at the bar would be a negative
reflection of the of the protagonist that he
didn't want to ever become and so he sees himself
in that guy at the bar and he go and the guy at
the bar is drunk and he's like yeah my ex-wife
she's a you-know-what and I just whatever I i I
walked out a long time ago and and hey johnny give
me another bourbon or whatever and then he sees
like I could become that man and I don't want to
be that and that straightens him out yep and that
so in that case then he's just a sub character
okay he doesn't have his own storyline okay
so he's not a subplot story yeah he's not
a subplot he's just a sub character he's just a
character who's helping to push the story forward
by his interaction with this guy but a story
line would mean that the guy at the bar
has his own goals and we're following
him trying to achieve those goals too
and then eventually they align with what everybody
else has going on I see okay so he's a catalyst
okay yeah interesting just coming in to push you
in one direction or the other because again if not
then we don't need him we don't need a guy who's
just at the bar being belligerent that that
belligerence should affect our guy in some kind
of way because if not then we don't need that.
What do you like about this video?